l'arrestation en yvan colonna constitue
donc une excellente nouvelle pour le
gouvernement est d'abord pour son
ministre de l'intérieur nicolas sarkozy
avait fait de ce dossier l'un de ses
principaux objectifs une priorité
nationale selon ses propres termes ce
matin lors d'une conférence de presse
nicolas sarkozy qui a démenti toute
négociation avec yvan colonna est revenu
sur les circonstances de son arrestation
s'il y avait une reddition
nous l'aurions bien sûr parfaitement
acceptée
est ce que qui que ce soit ici on peut
imaginer qu'il y ait une quelconque
négociation
je voudrais vous dire également une
chose c'est que le terrain était
extraordinairement difficile avec un
maquis en tram est de 51 m 90 parfois
nos auteurs ce qui fait que même à 30
mètres avec le peu d'hommes finalement
qui étaient sur le terrain le risque de
fuite était considérable ce qui fait
d'ailleurs que pour intervenir il a
fallu qu yvan colonna ce sorte de
l'endroit où il se trouvait passe par un
petit sentier pour que deux
fonctionnaires puissent l'interpeller je
puis vous dire par exemple c'était très
difficile de savoir dans lequel des
bâtiments de la bergerie où se trouvait
il était lui-même localiser et tant que
nous ne savions pas toute l'intervention
était extraordinairement
risqué